what is happening in the knitting world
at least is these people are not just
leaving nasty comments on people's
images they're actually going after
their businesses so what they do is
first off they pick out high-profile
people to go after because you don't
want to just go after like Suzi Q would
like to follow or if you're not gonna
make an impact that way so they go after
people that are influences in the
Knitting world and then what they do is
they direct message
all of the major knitwear designers or
knitting stores and they basically say
if you do not denounce these people we
are going to come after you too
[Music]
do you sense that we'll get to a whole
new way of looking at I think not only
just looking at the world as a general
idea but we're looking at work that
people are gonna realize they can tell a
commute and work from home and maybe
spend more time with their spouses and
maybe don't want to be on the road two
hours a day getting to work and
commuting in the rest of it well I think
it's going to have to you because so
many organizations and now have staffs
that are completely working home and a
lot of them kind of went there kicking
and screaming they got pushed off the
cliff now their staff is seeing well we
can make this work and we don't
necessarily always need to be in the
office and so it's going to have to
change the relationship I think it's
it's really funny I'm actually working
with a group of managers right now who
are transitioning their teams to working
virtually they almost have to go back to
basics and it's they just they they have
to like build their workspaces and teach
their teams how to out of tune in these
virtual environments but once they get
there they're going to be ok yeah you
think most people actually are better
left to their own devices or do you
think because we're social creatures we
a lot of us need to actually show up
somewhere and you've done different
clothes and you know behave differently
with other co-workers and things like
that yeah I think it's it's a little bit
of both to be honest we still need those
social interactions but also one of the
keys to working at home well is to have
a routine to get up to take a shower not
sit around in your PJs all day have a
dedicated work space and so that's and
that's part of what's gonna help people
maintain work/life balance and really be
able to focus their energy on the things
that matter and so I think you know
people people are figuring it out and
working from home is weird I mean you
know this it's like sometimes you you
forget to eat sometimes you forget what
time it is
you forget to stop working at 5 o'clock
and so people are having to tackle that
as well yeah when I was writing my book
I would go into our green room here
which is a bedroom and I would just
start at about 7:30 or 8:00 a.m. and I'd
be writing writing writing and then it
would literally be 2 p.m. and David
would basically slide a plate of food
through the door he would open up the
door slide it in not even bother me
because I would legitimately forget to
eat because I was so just in that zone
Oh
same on my book I was up here 1 2 a.m.
in the morning and I would go downstairs
my husband would be like what the heck
happened to you where did you go
and it's just the way it is when you get
into that flow of work yeah all right so
you're a psychologist and you're doing
some interesting stuff that obviously is
very relevant as we're talking about to
to the way we're all living right now
but what sort of put you on the map here
was this piece that you wrote that all
started well you were part of a knitting
community and we can all imagine how
radical the knitting communities are
tell me a little bit about the Knitting
communities online I'm not in the nating
world I don't know what's going on over
there I have respect for the knitters
but tell me about the Knitting community
Oh Dave prepare to have your mind blown
what's going on because this all started
about a year ago and the Knitting
community I'm talking about this is not
a knitting circle of little old ladies
this is mostly people of all different
ages Instagram kind of sharing their
projects and sharing their yarns and all
these things well about a year ago these
roving games of social justice warriors
started infiltrating different parts of
the knitting community and really
started going after and bullying and
mopping people very severely so it
started with a woman named Karen Templar
who wrote a blog post about her upcoming
trip to India and she was so excited
about going on this trip and it just she
thought it would never happened and she
was always scared to travel in all these
things and the sjw's mocked her so badly
because they said your other Emmure your
cullen saying all this stuff how dare
you and she had to write this full
retraction and apology and point out
every single thing that was wrong with
her blog post and it's several
paragraphs long it's crazy
so another woman Maria Tuscon was
watching that and she does these
beautiful hand dyed yarns and all Maria
did was post a video on YouTube saying
I'm not comfortable with what's going on
and I'm going to take some time off of
Instagram well they didn't like that and
they they went after her and mocked her
tried to destroy her business destroy
all her partnerships prove would post
horrible pictures of her on Instagram
like photoshopped into Klan uniforms and
things like that and so that was crazy
but the thing that really got my
attention was this one guy Nathan Taylor
he goes by the name
petition on Instagram and all he did
when all of this was going on was to
post a poem on a hashtag called
diversity asking for kindness asking for
people to be nice to each other and
where's the wrong things oh I know and
and you know any men the ironic thing
about him too is like it's a gay man in
the Knitting community so he's like that
a couple of minority cars in this
instance working for him
but for his efforts he was thanked by
being mobbed by hundreds and hundreds of
people to the point where he had a
nervous breakdown and went into the
hospital on suicide watch and I'm kind
of watching all this happen and like I
said my background is in workplace
bullying I've studied adults bullying
other adults extensively and I just
thought this is not what I signed up for
and these are people that I was aligned
with politically and it really if that
was my wake-up moment to say what is
going on in the world and do I want to
really be a part of this ok so there's
there's a lot there but the the sort of
bones of your story is the type of story
that I hear all the time I've had many
of my guests I've been through my own
version of it that you know you're
basically I think you can describe your
own political positions but you know you
think of yourself as sort of a good
lefty you're knitting this is sort of a
political next thing you know some
bizarre thing happens and everyone's a
racist and a bigot we're destroying
lives and all that did you have no sense
that any of this was going on within the
community or you actually use the word
infiltrated we're these Outsiders that
were coming in to suddenly wreak havoc
or were these people from within the
community themselves and I ask you this
because a lot of people these days are
now we're spending more and more time
online one of the things that I'm trying
to do with my new tech company locals
dock on is create protected communities
and people are trying to figure out how
can you gate a community and make sure
that all these bad actors you know don't
get in there no I think a lot of them
were actually part of the knitting
community and all of this too was
surrounding the site Ravelry which is
one of the most popular knitting sites
on the internet and what Ravelry did I
think midway through last year is they
banned all support for Donald Trump so
you are not allowed to
anything in the forums about supporting
him you were not allowed to post
patterns with like Trump 2020 or
anything like that and that fed into all
of this as well so what what would
happen is they would like coordinate on
Ravelry and then they would go forth and
bully people on Instagram I think so
what were the types of things that you
were seeing besides just oh you're evil
you're racist you're a bigot like they
were actually trying to go for people's
jobs and as you said I mean well at
least one guy had a mental breakdown
because of it but can you talk about
that because I think a lot of times
people that don't pay that much
attention to this stuff they're always
like oh well it's just some trolls on
Twitter and there's no real-world
consequences you know toughen up it's
what is happening in the Knitting world
at least is these people are not just
leaving nasty comments on people's
images they're actually going after
their businesses so what they do is
first off they pick out high-profile
people to go after because you don't
want to just go after like susie-q would
like to followers you're not gonna make
an impact that way so they go after
people that are influences in the
Knitting world and then what they do is
they direct message all of the major
knitwear designers or knitting stores
and they basically say if you do not
denounce these people we are going to
come after you too and so there are very
detrimental effects on people's
businesses and this is this is what
their livelihood is and knitting
you know like spoiler alert Dave
knitting is not like a lucrative
business right we're talking about
getting that big knitting money no I
mean no I don't make my money from
knitting but no I mean they're they're
doing what they need to do to get by and
so it really does have a horrible impact
ok so what's interesting about this
because this is sort of a world it's a
very niche world that a lot of people
don't understand about but politically
now you mentioned the Trump thing
already that they one of the sides said
okay no more Pro Trump stuff you can't
knit a Trump sweater or anything like
that but politically speaking this is a
pretty female dominated lefty basically
right lefty ideologically dominated
arena so were you shocked I mean these
are the people that are supposed to be
tolerant and diverse and open and all of
those things and you considered yourself
one of them at least at the time
were you shocked and then how did that
then lead to I think what you would now
consider your political awakening yeah
so it was very shocking to me this was
not what I perceived the the good the
good tolerant liberals to be doing and
you know I frankly hadn't been paying
attention to a lot of this stuff that
was going on in the world I was busy I
was living my life and so to see how
this played out it really did make me
question everything about my belief
system and the people I had aligned
myself with yeah can you just go through
a little bit of what your political
leanings were beforehand yeah I've
called myself a liberal for like 20
years I've been a Democrat since I was
18 years old since I was able to
register to vote and frankly I never
really saw myself leaving the Democratic
Party up until all this started
happening if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell